welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss in the mandalorian chapter 12 just
confirmed some
critical connections between the series
and some of the most
controversial mysteries of the film saga
yes blue mill can be used to make
macaroons
and can become milk once more oh boy but
ever since the episode came out last
week
the clues us nerds have been trying to
unpack over these past several days have
centered around the question
of why these imperial forces want baby
yoda's blood
and the timeline of how this all
connects to the sequel trilogy events
for which this mando episode just gave
us the
big missing link john favreau and dave
bologna essentially said
all that confusing backstory with the
first order of snoke palpatine
trust us we're gonna clear that up with
baby yoda i started to explain some of
this in our breakdown of the episode but
in this video i am just going to do a
deep dive
on this connection the full implications
the timeline
the bloodline the hotline to call when
your baby od's on cookies
let's actually start there with the
child what does the empire want with the
child back in chapter three of last
season when amanda went back for the
child he heard
this exchange between the client and dr
pershing extract
the necessary material and mando found
dr pershing
analyzing baby yoda with an imperial
probe droid which we know
comes packing with syringes of all kinds
definitely capable of extracting blood
we also spotted a patch on dr pershing's
shoulder with insignia similar to kamino
insignia seen in that cloning facility
that also
showed up on the scientists in this
episode now later on in season one we
got a sort of confirmation that the
child himself must not be a clone but
born naturally
and just wanted for future cloning
reasons i don't think it was engineered
i've worked in the gene farms this one
looks
evolved and now according to dr
pershing's correspondence with moff
gideon in the recent episode
that plan is to harvest the child's
midichlorian rich blood
and then inject it into new genetically
engineered bodies
i highly doubt we'll find a donor with a
higher m count though we have
exhausted our initial supply of blood
and i was only able to harvest
a limited amount without killing him if
these experiments are to continue has
requested we would again require access
to the donor
m count obviously referring to
midichlorian count
that whole idea george lucas introduced
in the phantom menace that ties one's
force
sensitivity to the measure of microbial
organisms
in one's cells anakin skywalker clocked
in at 20 000
higher than master yoda himself so this
tells us that the cloner scientists like
dr
pershing are working for imperial
loyalists like moff gideon to harvest
blood
of force sensitive beings like baby yoda
to create
new force sensitive life forms clones
frankenstein
freak shows most of which failed to
survive which we saw in those creepy
tanks in the navarro imperial
lab so what will baby yoda's blood be
used for
there appears to be a secret plot by the
remnants of the empire to
resurrect emperor palpatine and they
need force sensitive blood
to be put in a compatible host body a
flesh puppet
so that palpatine's disembodied spirit
can inhabit it and live
once more with the ability to use the
force actually the opening scenes of the
rise of skywalker started to show this
kylo ren followed palpatine's ghost
voice to exigal
where hooded sith scientists toiled away
in a lab with various humanoid cloned
bodies in
tanks and one of those half-baked clones
was revealed to be
palpatine the resistance meanwhile
speculated on how this was possible
dark science cloning
secret sony that's it and that is as far
as jj abram's script went into it you
can thank the studio for
insisting palpatine return for episode
nine it's insane
it's actually getting more insane
moments but not at all planning that out
with jj abrams from the beginning of the
reboot trilogy
so after ryan johnson killed off snoke
in the last jedi
and since they i guess didn't want to
make kylo ren a villain which they just
should have
they decided to retcon snoke as a kind
of step along the way
toward the true evil palpatine 2.0 snoke
trained you well i killed snoke i'll
kill you
i made smoke i have been
every voice you have ever heard
inside your head and yes they included a
shot of multiple
snoke clones in tanks this mandalorian
episode
similarly lingers on a shot of what
looks to be a similar snoke form
same bulbous splintered skull same
facial features
so we can conclude from this that snoke
was
one finally successful test subject from
this secret project which would mean
in the near future some midichlorian
donor will likely get drained
and maybe die that fateful donor could
be
the child or it could be a socatano
or hopefully some loser sith apprentice
because i don't think we want any force
sensitive character that we like to give
up their lives so that we end up with
this
but uh before we continue thank you to
skillshare for sponsoring this video
skillshare is an online learning
community that offers membership with
meaning
with so much to explore real projects to
create and the support of fellow
creatives
skillshare empowers you to accomplish
real growth skillshare offers classes
designed for real life you can learn and
grow with short classes that fit
any schedule spontaneous acts of
creativity may help break up the routine
of a day spent indoors and learning is a
great way to fend off that boredom they
have classes and topics new rockstars
fans will enjoy like
animation film video and music
production a class i want to check out
is creative writing crafting personal
essays with impact stopped by
best-selling author roxanne gay
the class focuses on how to find your
story craft your truth and to write to
make a difference
at a time when so many important
conversations are happening in our world
your voice is more essential than ever
explore classes to unlock that
creativity for social good
skillshare is curated specifically for
learning there are no ads and they're
always launching new premium classes so
that you can stay focused
and follow wherever your creativity
takes you and it's less than ten dollars
a month with an annual subscription
and the first 1000 people to use the
link in the description will get a free
trial of skillshare premium membership
so jump on this and thanks again to
skillshare for helping us make this
video okay dr pershing also mentioned a
mysterious volunteer
that he wanted to halt the experiments
in order to keep from dying
that vip volunteer might be palpatine's
son shown briefly in a flashback in the
rise of skywalker who fled he hid his
daughter rey on jakku and was shortly
after killed by the assassin uchi
i also pointed out the breakdown some
other test subjects visible in those
tanks one of which the closing credits
concept art depicts as
matching the silhouette of a zabrak
maybe setting us up for a resurrection
of maul
that was at least being considered after
his death shortly before these events in
rebels
everybody coming back and what does this
tell us about the first order
that pre-snoke in the tank hints that
this must be connected
to the first order's rise after all back
in september 2019 dave filoni and john
favreau themselves suggested in an
interview that this series would at some
point
explain the circumstances by which the
first order came about so just to catch
you up about a year after the empire's
defeat in the battle of endor the
remaining imperial forces rallied for
one last stand at the battle of jakku
that was in 5 aby
that would be 4 years or so before the
events of mandalorians set in 9 aby
the ruins of that battle of jakku is
what rey scavenges decades later in the
force awakens
after that battle one imperial star
destroyer the eclipse
made it out of there they fled with a
bunch of imperial child
soldiers and from that the first order
rose decades later they made their first
big moves
around 28 aby which was about six years
before the force awakens and around that
time they got on everyone's map in a
very big way
now snoke came to rule the first order
under mysterious circumstances
no one really knows where that guy came
from until the rise of skywalker
suggested snoke was planted there
as a puppet by palpatine and apparently
that was something the first order never
really knew
so now i think we are seeing the
palpatine side of that operation
the operation that created snoke to
install him
in the first order leadership that would
make moth gideon working directly
underneath
palpatine as opposed to him being in the
mix of the first order gideon's
possession of the darksaber suggests an
interest at least in the culture of the
jedi and sith so
he must be currently heading up the
secondary empire operation
behind the first order one that led to
the final order
the secret sith fleet on exigal so just
to clarify we have
two post-imperial factions in the
shadows during this era one
the first order run by snoke who was a
puppet ruler spawned by
midichlorian transfusion cloning
experiments of the second faction
who conducted those experiments in order
to try to resurrect palpatine
both of these factions lurk in the blind
spots of the new republic the concerned
mentioned by new republic x-wing pilot
captain carson tiva
there's something going on out here they
don't believe it on the core worlds but
it's true these aren't isolated
incidents
they need to be stopped before it's too
late maybe he's worried about the threat
of the first order starkiller based on
ilum which might have been that ice
planet we saw back in chapter 10
that's why tevo could have been
patrolling that area or
palpatine's new sith fleet being
constructed on hexagonal
both of which are definite existential
threats that you should be worried about
if you want to support this channel in
our never-ending quest for star wars
easter eggs
you can buy shirts like this one at our
official merch store
newrockstarsmerch.com it's filled with
fun nerdy designs shirts hoodies masks
we got everything there and yeah
subscribe to this channel hit that
notification bell follow me on instagram
at eavos follow new rockstars thank you
for watching
i have spoken
[Music]
you